crowds queued at the parliament to see
one woman conchita worse i'm here to see
a conchita because
the daughter my daughter and the
friend's daughter have made this great
poster and i think the message going out
to the world is we are all different
and luckily we are different and
hopefully people are tolerant the
austrian singer broke boundaries and
cemented her place in history when she
won this year's eurovision song contest
with her song rise like a phoenix
and amongst the fans queueing up the
first rugby team in brussels made up
mainly of gay men what did they think it
meant that conchita was here at the
parliament well it has the message of
the european union spreading the values
of tolerance and respect to diversity
and a quick autograph from conchita go
and see them
they're great but it wasn't just the
crowds that conchita had come for
earlier on in the day she had held a
joint press conference conchita voice
has made it here to brussels today
conchita wurst has a very important
political message it has to do
with what the european union stands for
equal rights fundamental rights the
right to live your life without fear
european leaders have increasingly
voiced support for an eu strategy on
lgbt human rights this can india
familiar passion
ministerium indian sport foreign
at the press conference conchita said
her eurovision win was a big statement
from europe to the world
and to all those who have suffered
discrimination she called on them to
have the confidence to be who they are
but over to the concert where hundreds
of smiling faces braved the rain to see
here
in the short time the world has known
her has become a big symbol and judging
by the throngs of people that came to
see her she's here to stay